hi everyone
i am a senior product manager at alexa
ai working on alexa conversations
today with my colleagues mariam and adam
we're going to be walking you through
how you can create natural multi-turn ai
driven experiences
using alexa conversations its benefits
and how it works to begin with and to
set some context
i want to start off with talking about
skills on alexa
think of skills as different
capabilities that alexa offers
and these may be experiences that are
built by amazon
alexa internal teams partner amazon
teams
or even external developers and
companies
today there are more than 100 000 skills
on alexa reaching customers on more than
100 million alexa enabled devices
four out of five alexa customers with an
echo device
use skills today there are hundreds of
thousands of alexa developers building
skills that are available in over 80
countries
and 13 language variants
skill builders are creating innovative
experiences today by using alexa's
automatic speech recognition and
natural language understanding
technologies to let people use their
voices naturally to interact with
content
services and devices
at the top level there's two broad
categories of interactions with alexa
the first category is one-shot
interactions
this is really where alexa started and
they have given a lot
of the growth in the lecture these are
interactions where the user goes to
alexa and says do x and alexa does it
the user gives a command which is
intercredit and sent to the backend
which does some work
and sends back and i'm done confirmation
for example this could be things like
checking the latest news or weather
adding something to your grocery list or
smart home interactions where you're
turning on or off the lights
for skills there is an interaction model
that is represented
by intents that the developer believes
the user's requests
represent and corresponding statements
that the user may say
this is used to formulate a back-end
model representation
for understanding the user which works
really well for one-shot interactions
on the other hand where we see a lot of
the innovation turn into in the next
several years
is around multi-turn interactions
multi-turn interactions allow alexa to
have
a more in-depth interaction and back and
forth with the customer
to really understand what exactly it is
that they're trying to achieve
the core of this presentation is around
how we can build
more natural multi-term conversations
for alexa and you'll see examples of it
come through all
the presentation what you see here on
the screen
is an example of a pet map skill that
helps the customer go through and find a
specific breed of dog
that meets their criteria so what you
see
is the customer starting out super broad
getting into the experience
just requesting what dog breed is good
for me
there's a lot of filters that could be
applied so in order to hone in
on what the customer really wants and
provide the best result back to them
alexa is able to ask for additional
parameters
and she comes back with what are two
things you're looking for in a dog
customer responds with i want a big
friendly dog so now big and friendly are
slots
or entity values that alexa is going to
use to filter the results
and comes back with another follow-up
question saying do you prefer high
energy or low energy dogs
and a result a response of high energy
from the customer
then results in alexa being able to take
those three pieces of
input big friendly and high energy
and come back with a recommendation of a
labrador
trigger so this represents a multi-turn
interaction where there's a
bunch of back and forth between the
customer and alexa
you see alexa and the customer really
working in a joint manner
to determine the best result
and where the customer asks for
something instead of just coming back
with some response
there's a bunch of information exchange
allowing alexa to have more complex
interactions
and do more innovative things in turn
allowing her to provide
more and better results and really this
is where
like i said we see a lot of the
innovation happening over the next
couple of years
i'm going to show you a video of now
a fairly complex well-executed
multi-turn conversation
alexa what are the show times for dark
phoenix on saturday after 9 pm
here are the show times for dark phoenix
on june 8th after 9 pm
get me two tickets for 10 35
okay two adult tickets for the 10 35 pm
show of dark phoenix on saturday june
8th at regal cinema palace station will
be 21
should i book the tickets wait how long
is it
dark phoenix is 1 hour and 52 minutes
long
actually what are the show times after 7
p.m
here are the show times for dark phoenix
on june 8th after 7
p.m get me two tickets for the 705 show
instead
okay two adult tickets for the 705 pm
show of dark phoenix on saturday june
8th at regal cinema
palace station will be 21. should i book
the tickets
yes please you will receive an email
from adam tickets with your tickets
all right so coming back at the surface
that seems really like a pretty natural
and straightforward interaction between
the user and alexa
but in reality if you dig in a little
bit
there is a lot that's going on that was
a fairly complex example of a user
trying to find and purchase some movie
tickets with them
actually changing some of their
decisions along the way while performing
other sidebar actions like trying to get
some more information on the movie
itself
let's take a look at some of the
challenges in particular
so first off there's this concept of
entity resolution
and disambiguation in the earlier
portion of the video the user says
get me two tickets for 10.35 from the
left hand side of the screen
you can see there's a few options that
are listed for the movie dark phoenix
there's regal cinema palace station emc
town square and
legal texas station and when they use
assassin 35
they don't necessarily specify which
theater
the system is able to resolve and
identify the appropriate theater as an
illegal cinematic palace without the
user having to mention that
this in the back end is actually a hard
thing to do
but it was done in a natural
free-flowing way
and sort of just goes by in the
conversation
next we have a representation of mixed
initiative
where you see both parties are engaged
in the conversation
and really have the ability to drive it
in any direction they want
for example we see through the dialogue
where alexa and the user are both asking
questions and there's this back and
forth
and it's fairly easy for anybody to take
control of the conversation and steer it
where they want to take it
as alexa is going down the path of
completing the purchase for the customer
and says should i book the tickets
the user is able to take a step back and
say hey wait
how long is it and take the
conversation down a completely different
path in this case
inquiring about more details about the
movie
and at that point alexa is not just able
to respond but she's also able to move
the conversation forward
there's also this notion of um
conversational context and capturing it
and retaining it through the dialogue
this something that we as humans do
really well with the ability to
compartmentalize
our manually with short-term and
long-term data
pulling relevant context as we engage in
conversations
for virtual assistants though context is
a much harder problem
here you see alexa is able to actually
track that
so at the very end when the user says
what are the show times after 7pm she's
able to refer back to the earlier part
of the conversation
where there was a discussion around
looking for a move for movie show times
for dark phoenix
without the user having to say what are
the showtimes after 7pm
for the movie dark phoenix but just
express it very naturally so
all through this conversation there's
this context that's maintained and the
user and
alexa are able to refer to elements of
it
in a natural manner and continue the
conversation forward
now all three of these things entity
resolution and disambiguation mixed
initiative
maintaining conversation with context
are fairly complicated but when done
well the beauty of it really lies
in making it seem like it was just a
simple part of the natural flow of
conversation without any added burden
on the user and a very seamless
experience
let's now talk about the system that
really made
the experience that you saw possible
the experience that you saw earlier is
running on what is called a dialogue
management system
and balance managers really do three key
things
firstly they maintain conversational
state which
involves tracking entities that may be
extracted during the conversation
based on what the user said or some
back-end process
results that um as an outcome of the
interaction with the user
for example the user search for movie
times
for dark phoenix the dialogue manager is
further responsible for ensuring that
the state is captured and refreshed as
needed so that the information does not
become stale
and that becomes one of its primary
tasks
secondly the dialogue manager prompts
the user to help drive the conversation
to the next date for example in the
context of the video that you saw
pc alexa trying to confirm if the user
wants to book the tickets
that's a way for her to move the
conversation forward driving you to the
next stage of achieving the goal
that appears to be progressive seems to
be making a movie ticket purchase
and third time managers are responsible
for interpreting
the user's response contextually
a very common and great example of this
is
a user responding with a yes or no to a
question we do that very normally
the system really needs to know what
their response was in context
to be able to take appropriate action
so going back to the pet match
conversation
that we discussed when talking about
multi-turn interactions
this dialogue represents a happy path
experience
with the customer to provide a dog
recommendation
the customer is asked a series of
questions
and once all necessary information has
been provided the skill
makes a recommendation this particular
conversation as you see over here
consists of three turns or back and
forth exchanges
as shown on the screen
let's take a look at how one single term
comes together
when alexa asks the user do you prefer
high energy or low energy dots it's
same dialogue state a with
the user's response of high energy that
triggers some processes that then
ends up moving the system back and state
now dialogue state
it's a very small zoomed in version of a
very simple
single dialogue plan now zooming
out a bit if you put a bunch of these
turns together
in this particular image each blue dot
represents a state of the conversation
the blue arrows represent the intended
direction
and the number of numbered arrows
actually represent the path
so if you look at it in the situation we
have six turns
before we get to the final response and
the
above situation is called
a multi-linear multi-turn interaction
and this case is incredibly easy to
build with a simple intent uptrend space
solution
they're very easily designed and built
out
but it really drives very linear and
repeatable
and somewhat boring and non-engaging
experiences
linear multi-turn experiences tend to
follow a happy path
where the when you assume the user is
complying with your requests for
information
and the experience is proceeding as
desired with nothing really out of blue
happening
what happens if the customer does
deviate from this happy path
end up with something like that
so we often see the experience that
customers want it's a little more
complex
so in this representation instead of a
step-by-step experience that proceeds
linearly
it's a multi-dimensional array where you
could move from state a
to b and then the user responds with
something that's completely unrelated to
maybe what you planted for and now you
need to jump to
a completely different state
very natural for conversations to
deviate from a predetermined script
example in the case of the ticket
purchase the user decided to ask
for the duration of the movie instead of
confirming whether they wanted to go
through with the purchase
the user could provide more information
than required at times or less
and there could be some mixed initiative
happening there's so many
edge cases in respect match use case you
can imagine a situation where the user
corrects a piece of information
so there could be loops within a dialog
state and back to a stage
for example the user previously
indicated they wanted a large dog and
then as they proceed
they decide to revisit the parameter by
saying
how many pounds is a large dog and four
outfits oh you know what
make it a small now this needs to be
tracked by the dialog manager
to ensure the state
is captured appropriately the dialog
manager needs to be able to take the
information offered contextualize
it and continue to drive the
conversation forward towards
final end goal if these edge cases
mixed initiatives user collections
overfilling under filling
that clearly drive the complexity of
these experiences and we're seeing these
happen more and more these days
alexa conversations is a deep learning
approach
that developers can use to create
natural voice
experiences for alexa this could mean
creation of entirely new skills
or it could also be used in conjunction
with custom skills to build on just a
portion of the scale
and this three main benefits
that you see in
using alexa conversations
let's do a quick overview of the system
in itself and how it solves
the complex problem of creating
natural multitude experiences as you saw
represented in the non-linear state
graph
while making these experiences feel
natural
and seamless alexa conversations
enables more conversational experiences
without requiring additional developer
from
effort for feature building from
developers
we find uh that they're able to add new
cases
because of the added simplicity and
we're taking away a lot of the
complexity
uh through the bunch of features that
make it easier for the developers to
adopt
and deploy robust and natural
experiences to customers
and finally we're able to do this with
lesser backend code for dialogue state
management and also with lesser modern
training data as compared to what we
need
to provide for custom skills today
so just to reiterate when we talk about
conversational interactions we're
talking about experiences that need
support for
contextual carryover user-driven
interactions
slot over and under filling things that
tend to happen very naturally over the
course of conversations that we have
with people
and what we're able to do with alexa
conversations
is offer developers the ability to
support these capabilities
in their experiences inherently and
bring them into the conversations and
interfaces
presented by alexa
here's an example of contextual
carryover
alexa starts by asking for two things
the user is looking for in a dog to
which they respond
with wanting a small family dog
with those two entity attributes in mind
alexa responds with a puppy pentagon
recommendation
the user comes back now and adds another
attribute
saying what about a guard dog
so now alexa is able to use the previous
context of also wanting
a small family dog and query the
relevant api
and come back with a recommendation of a
beagle which satisfies
small family and guard dog without
needing to read from the customer so as
you can see
this can contextual carry over being
used over here
for driving a user-driven update of
entities to drive
a more natural experience
what else alexa conversation supports
several
advanced dialogue management features
we've already spoken
about visual corrections a lot of
overfilling and underfilling
so i want to really quickly call out one
more that we haven't really mentioned
previously
and that is list entity management
with this you are now able to say
something like
uh add grades spares and apples to my
shopping cart and have the system really
recognize that grapes
pairs and others are all individual
items
and have the system um
put all of these individual items into
your shopping desk
all the parsing and management is
handled behind the scenes for you so now
you could actually follow up
within the conversation with specific
updates to each of these items
as well very easily if you wanted
support of such features is now enabling
use cases that
weren't previously possible
unfortunately
and finally
like we discussed alexa conversations
needs fewer lines of training data
here's a comparison um based on one of
our earlier experiments that we did with
the movie recommendation skill
the skill is very similar to what you
saw in the experience
and the original skill that was created
using standard custom
skill practices needed about 16 60 lines
of interaction model data and
5 500 lines of back-end code to track
where the user was in the dialogue
and manage it once we move that and
ported that over to alexa conversations
we were able to write down the number of
lines of
data for model training 440.
so that's pretty significant 155
lines of api definition which really
involves describing
what endpoints are you planning to call
from your skill
when you get discussive parts of your
dialogue
and what information needs to be passed
back and forth
we also have 370 lines of response
templates which basically contains
responses that alexa needs to offer
back to the customer during the course
of the dialogue and this includes
templated values
and the blank is filled in with the
beagle
when the recommendation is made for
example
uh and uh
the backing code came down from 5500
lines
to 1700 lines of code because state
management
was now taken care of so all in all
alexa conversations really reduces a lot
of the overhead and burden
on developers for creating these
multitude
experiences and uh
we're excited to see how new experiences
can be built
and brought to our customers
to solve more and more complex problems
and goals
thank you
hi i'm marion and i'm a senior applied
scientist at alexa natural understanding
today i'm going to go into a technical
deep dive of alexa conversations
let's start by discussing the dialogue
simulator which is the component that
generates dialog variations
in addition to the dialogues that the
developer writes
the generated syntactic dialogues may
deviate from happy paths
or they may contain alternate paths that
the dialogue can take
this ensures that we generate enough
dialogue variations
to make the skills conversational models
robust to different user behaviors
the dialog simulator takes the build
time inputs that the developer has
provided
including the api and slot definitions
response templates and sample dialogs
and generate synthetic dialogues in two
steps
the first step the dialog simulator
generates different dialog flows
which are alternate paths that the
conversation can take
in the second step we inject natural
language variations into the dialog
flows these are paraphrases of what the
user can say
to communicate with alexa for example
they can say
recommend a movie or i want to watch a
movie
finally after these two steps the
simulator is able to generate tens of
thousands of dialogues
that we use to train this use
conversational models
so let's go into more details about how
the dialogue simulator works
we can look at a goal-oriented dialogue
as a kind of a game between a user and
alexa
in this case the user has a goal which
can be an information need
or a task that needs to be accomplished
and alexa doesn't know what the user
wants to do
but has access to some apis and
resources to help the user achieve their
goal
so in this example the user's goal is to
find out about the weather
and alexa has access to an api that can
look up the weather for a particular
city on a particular day
this is not like most games we see this
is more of a collaborative game
in which the conversation participants
take turns and perform actions
in order to achieve their goals using
this
approach let's go over an example of how
this simulator
generates dialogues at the beginning
the user has a goal so we stochastically
sample a user goal
the user then informs their goal by
saying what's the weather
from the alexa side this looks like
calling the getweather api
but alexa sees that it needs more
information to be able to address the
user's goal
so it requests some slot values in this
case the city and date
so alexa responds with which city and
for which day
user informs the slot values seattle
today
and alexa confirms to make sure it
understood correctly
to the to which the user can affirm or
deny or affirm oneness law
and deny another slot here the user
affirms by saying yes and finally alexa
makes the api call and informs the
weather results to the user
in this example the user was asking for
the weather
in a particular city on a particular
date
so we see that as we go through the
dialogue the user's behavior
is consistent with the goal the same
goal of course
may be achieved through different
dialogue paths
and simulating this is important because
in real life
users display different behaviors when
interacting with skills
for example you can see on the left hand
side the case where the user is more
cooperative
when alexa asks for the city they use a
response by giving both city
and a tomorrow in seattle in this case
alexa understands that the date is
already provided
and doesn't ask for it again in the
middle example
the user is less cooperative when alexa
asks for city and date they only provide
the day
which is tomorrow and alexa understands
that it needs to request the date again
in the right example you can see a case
where the user is changing their mind
user first asks for weather in seattle
but then changes the location to boston
alexa understands the change of location
correctly
and requests the date again here i gave
example of simulating different user
behaviors but we also simulate different
alexa behaviors
for example we simulate alexa
proactively offering a skill
functionality
that is related to what the user is
doing
and we also simulate confirming a slot
values or apis
simulating these behaviors gives us
dialog pad variations
in order to make our conversational
models robust to such behaviors
without requiring the developers to do
the extra effort of writing
these dialogues in addition to dialogue
path variation
it's also important to have language
variations since different users can
state the same goal differently
one way to achieve this is to do catalog
sampling for these slot values
so if we have the utterance what's the
weather in seattle today
we can sample the catalogs for city and
simulate a dialogue varying
and we can do this for more than one
slot as well
this yields dialogues with diverse slot
values
if the developer has provided variants
for an utterance with different argument
order
the simulator will also generate
dialogues with such variations
we also use paraphrases generated by a
paraphrase model
to generate additional language
variations
and finally we simulate speech
recognition errors and
interpretation errors because in real
life alexa
could make mistakes and misunderstand
the user
so we want our models to be robust to
such errors
some of the errors can be automatically
recovered
for example here the misrecognized for
can be corrected to f or ur but in other
cases
it may be necessary to confirm the
understanding
with the user and allow them to correct
any errors
so how do we know if this is a good
simulator one way is to measure the
amount of
variation that the simulator introduces
here we have three tasks of getting
weather information
finding and booking movie tickets and
ordering rideshare
for each one we compare between just
adding language variations
to the sample dialogues the developer
has provided
and generating both language and
dialogue path variations with the
simulator
for each case we look at the number of
turns per dialog
the number of unique dialog flow
sequences
and entropy of the distribution of
complete dialogue act sequences
the dialogues generated with only
language variations
are identical to the sample dialogues
provided by the developer
in terms of dialogue path and show a
smaller variation
entropy when we are considering dialogue
path variations as well
we are simulating different
configurations of
arguments and user behaviors such as
user changing their mind or
alexa confirming is understanding
and so we get diverse dialogue samples
and we see an increase in entropy this
sometimes may also lead to longer
dialogues
so now i will go over the conversational
models that we use in alexa
conversations
these motors are built using the latest
deep learning techniques
to ensure the latest a state-of-the-art
performance to our users
the first model is the named entity
recognition model or ner
we have already talked about slots on
how they are backed up by catalogs
a slots are units of information that
need to be passed to the api or to the
response templates
the ner model takes the user utterance
and extracts the slots from user
utterance
so for example when the user says
seattle today
the nur model will recognize that
seattle is a city
and today is a date
for this we apply feature extractors to
extract
turn-level and dialog level features and
pass them through context encoders
we also extract catalog features based
on the domain and specific catalogs
provided by the developer
we then concatenate the feature
representations
to obtain the final dialog
representation
and con and concatenate it with word
embedding of each token
and use it as input to the model
for the final model we use birth with a
biolistim
architecture the second model
that we use is the action prediction
model or ap
the action prediction model predicts
what action
alexa should take next using the current
user utterance
and also taking into account the whole
dialogue history so far
so in this case after the user says
seattle today
the action prediction model looks at
this input
and the whole conversation and predicts
the best action to take next
is to confirm what the user just said
the action prediction model evaluates
different alternative possible adnex
actions for this we pass the dialog
encoding that i mentioned in the
previous slide
through an mlp and we utilize
endless action hypotheses using a simple
binning strategy
and reject actions in the low confidence
bin
and finally
the last model we have argument filling
this model plus in the values of api and
response template arguments
by looking at the whole dialog context
so far
it does this by picking a slot values
from all the compatible slots that the
ner model recognized earlier
so in this example when the user said
seattle today the ner model
already recognized seattle as a city and
today as a date
and the action prediction model already
decided
that the best thing to do is to confirm
so the argument filling model now goes
ahead
and selects the value seattle as the
input value for the city argument of the
confirm template
and the value today as the input for the
data argument
we model argument filling as a variation
of neural reading comprehension
and use an attention plus pointing
mechanism
we impose constraints to only fill
arguments with a slot of the correct
type
according to the action schema
so we put the simulator and model
together and here we evaluated the train
models on a ticket booking test
with 50 dialogues again we compare
trained models
on training data with only language
variations
and on training data with both language
and dialogue path variations
also for comparison we have models
trained with one thousand
and ten thousand simulated dialogues we
see that in both cases
going from one thousand to ten thousand
dialogues improves all three models
and the models trained with dialog flow
variations
significantly outperform the models
trained with only surface form
variations
this also shows the effectiveness of our
data generation
strategy
this completes the technical deep dive
thank you very much for listening
hi my name is adam hasham and i'm a
senior product manager with lexa skills
kit
i'm going to walk through creating and
annotating a dialogue using the
developer portal which is what you can
see on the screen over here
dialogues are foundational to creating
alexa conversational models
they stitch together alexa conversation
components
which are utterance sets slots api
indications
or api definitions and responses now the
best way to get started
is to create a skill using a hosted
template uh which is what i've got
kind of started over here i've loaded up
the hosted template called weatherbot
weatherbot is a conversational skill
that allows users to receive
brief weather updates for a given
location and dates
now within this weatherbot template i'm
going to walk through the creation of a
dialogue called
get weather requesting arg this
represents a simple back and forth
conversation
where the user wants the weather and
alexa requests the missing details
in order to provide it so we'll get
started with this empty dialogue
and then go through the two phases of
authoring first phase is
entering the surface form dialogue and
the second phase is annotating this
surface form dialogue and each of the
utterances uh with all the alexa
conversation components
so let's start by entering the surface
form dialogue phase one
so we'll start the user um with
deodorants
what's the weather um
alexa will respond within what city
and the user can respond with seattle
which is where i am now
uh and we're going to do a confirmation
to make sure we've got all the
information correctly so just to
confirm you want the weather
in seattle uh we'll affirm with yes
and do an api call here and respond with
today
in seattle the high is 92. we'll make it
summer
at a low of 65 degrees
great now you'll notice
we have these blue circles with
exclamation marks this this indicates
that the
the work's not done there's still uh the
next phase to go through which is the
the annotation process
um so let's start with the first with
the first turn with the first address so
the user says what's the weather
uh i'll select the dialog act invoke
apis
now invoke apis indicates that the user
is expressing an intention to eventually
invoke an api
uh which is how we're going to get the
weather information now the apis aren't
invoked on this turn
but this starts the user on a journey to
eventually invoke an api
later on and the dialogue now the two
general use cases for this dialogue act
number one is the very first turn of a
dialogue number two
is after an alexa turn with dialogue api
success or api failure which we'll get
to over here
now i've already created an utterance
set uh called get weather so
i'll just select it over here and if i
jump into it by clicking the edit button
i can see
all the different utterances that that
can also represent
they can also be used for the same turn
uh and this is information that the the
simulator actually
uses to expand upon when uh generating
training data for the alexa
conversations model
so i can add uh an additional sample
address here
uh whether please and
and this gets added uh to this data set
as soon as i hit save
and it's now once they build the model
it'll be part of the model
now the next turn uh we need to get some
more information from the users so i'm
going to select
the dialogue act and uh this is a
different set of dialogue acts
for the user it likes to turn i'm going
to select request args
now request args indicates that alexa is
requesting arguments that belong to the
api from the user
these arguments will eventually be used
to invoke an api
but again the api isn't invoked on this
turn
it'll be done in the later turn so i'll
select the get weather api which is the
the only api available in my skill model
today
uh and automatically it'll be pre-filled
with city name
um this is the argument that we're going
to be requesting
um and we've already got this request
city response
that's been previously created i can
jump into this
and over here we can select different
responses
or a visual response that will be used
on
a device like an echo show i can also
add arguments that are passed in
to be able to to render the response and
create the response
but in this particular utterance it's
not relevant
so let's take a look at what the audio
response looks like so if i click
edit audio response i can see
what's called an apla document now this
document
basically constructs variations of
responses and i can i can it's a
powerful tool i can use it for many
different applications from
randomly selecting prompts to make
things sound more natural
or or building them together in a
sequential way
so in this example the speech is
actually broken into a few parts so the
first part
the the prompt is going to say either
okay or short
or nothing for the second piece it'll
say four
or nothing and uh the third piece it'll
say which
what's we have what twice and the last
thing it'll say is city so there's
different
ways to kind of construct this this
response or this prompt
so let's go through let's let's hear
kind of what it might sound like so
hit play four which
city so you get four which city and if i
hit play again we should get a different
response hopefully
sure four what city
um no we can keep going okay four which
city so just by constructing the prompt
in this format we can create
uh uh you know quite quite a way to like
variety to help alexa sound a bit more
natural
so i'll close close this tab this is uh
we have the green check mark so we know
we finished this turn
and next we'll go into the user turn for
seattle where we're actually providing
information
so this is the dialog act and form args
now inform marks indicates that the user
is informing the value of arguments
being slots
that will you know eventually be used to
invoke an api
so in this case we're informing that the
valley seattle will be received by
um by city name and slot type
so if i double click over here i can
actually annotate this and i can select
the slot type
city name and i create a variable name
automatically
and i can edit this for changes to
something else that i like now this
variable name will be used
throughout the dialog in order to stitch
together the various components
so let's see what that looks like so
i've annotated seattle
uh that's sorted i can select my other
instead which i've already created and
i've got one called inform city
uh and this is going to include the
arguments city name zero or the variable
city means zero
uh which which helps pass in seattle
into this utterance set
um and just to see what kind of what
this looks like if i jump in over here
uh and this may help it make a little
bit more sense uh
so the user of this track in can respond
with something like seattle or they
could say tell me about seattle
what about seattle in seattle and we can
create a number of different variations
uh to expand that further
so now we've got the information
everything we need to make the api call
on this next turn
instead of making the apl directly which
we could do
instead we're going to do a confirmation
to make sure that we've got everything
right
so to do that i select uh confirm api
now this dialog act indicates that alexa
is confirming all the required api
arguments
uh and optionally any of the optional
api arguments that belong to the api
in this case we're doing the get weather
api yet
city names automatically pre-filled um
and now we can select our
response which has already been created
which is confirmed get weather response
and we can pass in city name zero as the
variable so this is the variable that
was collected on this term
so we brought in the argument assigned
it to a variable or button the slot
assigned it to a variable and now we're
taking the variable and assigning it to
the argument city name
to generate the response uh and just
take a quick look at what these
responses look like and how it brings in
that the city name um a couple of
variations they could say
just to confirm you want the weather
today in seattle or that was for seattle
or you'd like the weather in seattle is
that right so different ways to
randomly select uh the response um
to make make alexa effectively sound
more natural so let's save this
and we've now annotated this turn
so this next turn we're just affirming
so i can select a frame over here
uh we've got a pattern site called
confirm
getweather which is the affirmation um
and it's important to note that this is
clearly it's indicating that the users
are firming the request uh from the
previous alexa turn
uh but this a firm dialogue act almost
always follows either confirm
api or confirm arcs trick
so in this case we're following the
confirm api turn
it's also important to note that it's
actually not necessary to create a turn
with the deny dialogue act over here
this is because alexa conversations will
automatically support such negative use
cases on your behalf
if not explicitly provided so if a user
doesn't deny the confirm api
what will happen is if the user says no
the dialog will automatically exit and
alexa conversations will render the
wreck more response uh to keep the
conversation going
uh by default the recommend response is
along the lines of what do you want to
do so it's trying to restart the user
and re-engage them into the alexa
conversations
model so we've annotated less this
second last turn uh now getting to the
last turn now this is where
we're finally invoking the api so i'll
do a
api success and um
this indicates that alexa is like
basically notifying the user that the
api was successful
where success can be defined under
response condition over here which is
written
uh in a in a boolean um so over here
we'll select the api
get weather api i'm going to pass in the
variable city name which is pulled in
from here
and the return type which has already
been predefined uh is going to be
weather results
and it'll go into variable called
weather results
so after that api is called we'll have
to do a response so we can render
something back to the user
so we've got something pre-created here
called
gets weather response so select that
and we're going to use the weather
result 0 variable
and pass it into weather results
argument
and if i jump into this response over
here i can go back to editing
back into the apla editor and
we have a couple of like variations of
how to render this an example is today
and and then we have the city name it's
a high of
high temperature and a low of low
temperature and high temperature
low temperature and the city name were
actually all things that were
that were provided by the api itself
i didn't have to do that way i could
have also just had payload
dot city name and passed in city name as
an additional
um as an additional argument to the
response
but instead i chose to send that
information to the api
and use what we got back what was
returned from the api to
to render this this data
okay and save and there everything's
configured so all that's left to do is
build the model and then go on to the
testing tab to test and
play and interact with the skill thank
you
you